Now, InGrids, we allow any entity definition to have a physics object, that is
an entity doesn't inherit from physics object and isn't required to have one e.
Now from those daring digital souls who want one, they'll need to actually
create a handle to the physics body and keep it around over time so they can
manipulate it. Before they can do that, of course they have to first fill out
the entity definition object and pass that out to the gPhysicsEngine.addBody
which we've coded up previously. Now for grids, every object in the world is in
a box. So our description is pretty easy to generate. First off, we passed the
x and y position values to the class, alongside the halfWidth and halfHeight of
the box representing its size. In addition to that, box 2d expects some
specific surface properties such as dampening, friction, things along those
lines. So we go ahead and set them here as well if we want them.